الحوثيون يكشفون عن محتوى السفينه التي
استولوا عليها ونتنياهو يحمل ايران
المسؤوليه ملك الاردن يصرح سنرد بكل ما هو
مناسب على الهجوم العبري تقارير عبريه
تفجر مفاجاه صادمه تتعلق بهجوم السابع من
اكتوبر حامله المروحيات الفرنسيه تتجه الى
القطاع صحيفه بريطانيه تكشف كيف اصبح
نتنياهو يشكل عبءا ثقيلا على بايدن تهديد
ايراني شديد اللهجه للقوات الامريك هلع في
امريكا من انظمه التشويش الروسيه التي
تعطل الطائرات الاوكرانيه المسيره ثلاثه
جيوش اوكرانيه تم تدميرها والرابع سيلحق
بها ومصر تبدا اول خطوه في تشغيل مفاعلها
النووي عضو جديد في الحرب من الحدث امام
الكاميرات الى بدء الحرب اوفى الحوثيون
بوعودهم وبداوا اولى خطوات اليمن بالدخول
في الحرب وبعد ان اعلن المتحدث العسكري
باسم القوات المسلحه التابعه للحوثيين
العميد يحيى سريع في بيان الاستيلاء على
سفينه عبريه واقتيادها الى الساحل اليمني
مجددا تحذيره لكافه السفن العبريه او التي
تتعامل مع الكيان بانها سوف تصبح هدفا
مشروعا للقوات المسلحه وحسب موقع مارين
ترافيك فان السفينه كانت في البحر الاحمر
يوم السبت وكانت متجهه جنوبا فيما قالت
وسائل اعلام عبريه ان السفينه تابعه لشركه
راي شيبنج وكانت تحمل سيارات على متنها
هناك حمل نتنياهو الطهران مسؤوليه اختطاف
سفينه جلاكسي ليدر التي اقتاد الحوثيون
واحتجزوه معتبرا انها نزوه ايرانيه على
ذكر ايران فقد صرح وزير الخارجيه هناك
حسين امير عبد الله هيان بان طهران سترد
بشكل صارم على امريكا في حال قيام الجيش
الامريكي بهجوم على القوات الايرانيه في
سوريا واوضح عبد الله هيان ان وصول
الاسطول البحري الامريكي الى مياه شرق
البحر الابيض المتوسط لا يعتبر دليلا على
قوه امريكا بل انه يزيد من نسبه ضرر هذه
السفن في اي احتمال لياتي وزير الدفاع
العبري اف جالنت الذي اكد ان بلاده رصدت
اتجاها متزايدا من ايران لتكثيف هجماتها
عبر وكلائها والعدوان على الدوله العبريه
مضيفا ان ايران هي اصل العداء ومشيرا الى
ان مقاومه لبنان اطلقت اكثر من 1000 صاروخ
على الحدود الشماليه لكنها تدفع ثمنا
باهظا كل يوم اما في باريس فاعلنت الرئاسه
الفرنسيه استعداد لارسال حامله المروحيه
ديكس مود الى الشرق الاوسط في الايام
المقبله والمجهز لتقديم دعم طبي للقطاع
حسب ما افاد به قصر الاليزيه في الاردن
صرح الملك عبد الله الثاني بانه سيتم
اتخاذ كل الاجراءات المناسبه للتعامل مع
الهجوم العبري في محيط المستشفى الميداني
الاردني في القطاع واكد ان الاعتداء على
الكوادر الطبيه في المستشفى جريمه بشيعه
لنعود الى اجواء المعارك حيث كشف تحقيق
اولي لشرطه تلبيب ان مروحيه عبريه قامت
بقصف المشاركين في حفل مهرجان الطبيعه في
غلاف القطاع يوم السابع من اكتوبر الماضي
وان مقاتلي الفصائل لم يكونوا على علم
بوجود الحفل فيما نشرت شبكه ام بي سي نيوز
الامريكيه تقريرا يستعرض تزايد الشكوك في
مصداقيه الروايه العبريه منذ بدء هجومها
على القطاع واشار التقرير الى ان استخدام
تلبيب ادله مشكوكا فيها خلال اقتحامها
لمشفى الرنتيسي والشفاء في القطاع ادى الى
اضعا في مصداقيه الدوله العبريه هذا وقالت
صحيفه الجارديان البريطانيه ان النتنياهو
ب يشكل عبء على الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
واشارت الصحيفه الى ان دعم بايدن لتل ابيب
في حربها في القطاع يضر بفرص اعاده
انتخابه لولايه رئاسيه جديده كما يخسره في
معركه كسب الراي العام العالمي دوليا خرجت
مظاهره حاشده في مدينه لوزان السويسريه
مؤيده لشعب القطاع ومطالبه بوقف الهجوم
العبري فيما تظاهر عشرات الالاف في
باكستان في مدينه لاهور بشرق البلاد
احتجاجا على الحرب العبريه في القطاع حسب
ما ذكرت صحيفه التايمز اوف اسرائيل بينما
دعى الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الى اعاده
توحيد الضفه الغربيه والقطاع مستقبلا تحت
سلطه محليه متجدده في جنوب لبنان قالت
قناه العربي ان الاستهدافات مستمره بين
القوات العبريه ومقاومه لبنان وبواقع 15
استهدافا لمواقع عبريه وسط طقس تلفه امطار
غزيره ورياح شديده عطلت امام المسيرات
العبريه فيما كان الرد ب 50 قذيفه عبريه
بينها قذائف فسفوريه محرمه دوليا معارك
صاخبه صاخب المعارك لا يخفت ولا يتوقف في
اوكرانيا قال رئيس مقاطعه كورسك رومان
ستارو فويت عبر قناه تيليجرام ان نحو عشره
مبان خدميه واداريه تابعه لمؤسسه زراعيه
محليه تضر ردنا وقوع اصابات مضيفا انه تم
تسجيل سقوط 13 قذيفه جراء قصف القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه لقريه نيكولايف دينو
في المقاطعه هذا واعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه في تقريرها اليومي ان اجمالي
الخسائر البشريه للجيش الاوكراني على
مختلف محاور القتال بلغ نحو 605 عسكريين
فيما صرح المحلل الجيوسياسي والجندي
السابق في مشاه البحريه الامريكيه برايان
بليتك ان الجيش الروسي دمر ثلاثه جيوش
اوكرانيه في المنطقه العسكريه الشماليه
وفي خضم تصفيه الرابع هناك الصحفي
الامريكي جارلند نيكسون بان هزيمه
اوكرانيا ستتحول الى كارثه بالنسبه
لامريكا حيث ستفقد واشنطن مكانتها كقوه في
نظر المجتمع الدولي وتابع امريكا قالت
انها ستمنح اوكرانيا كل ما لديها ونتيجه
الان بوتين يفوز وهذه هزيمه كبرى لامريكا
من جهه اخرى قال المهندسون من شركه كوانتم
سيستمز الالمانيه التي تزود القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه بطائرات دون طيار ان
الروس قاموا بالتشويش على الاش الشارات
اللاسلكيه التي تربط الطائرات المسيره
بالاقمار الصناعيه ما ادى الى انحراف
الطائرات المسيره وسقوطها على الارض
واشارت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الى ان انظمه
الحرب الالكترونيه الروسيه تعمل على تعقيد
تشغيل الصواريخ المزوده بنظام توجيه جي بي
اس والطائرات دون طيار واي اتصالات
لاسلكيه من اوكرانيا الى مصر حيث اعلنت
هيئه المحطات النوويه لتوليد الكهربائ
هناك بدا التركيب من الصياده قلب المفاعل
للوحده النوويه الثانيه بمح مطه الضبعه
النوويه على الساحل الشمالي الغربي للبلاد
ووفقا للبيان اكد الوكيل ان مشروع المحطه
النوويه بالضبعه يسير بوتيره اسرع من
المخطط الزمني المقرر الانجازات فيه تحققت
في وقت قياسي غير
مسبوق
[موسيقى]
ي